the mughal dynasty is a fascinating
bunch these leaders of one of the most
significant empires in the history of
the indian subcontinent are all pretty
much very famous figures emperors like
akhbad who have already made an episode
on
jahangir and aurangzeb are all very
famous historical figures
and sometimes for very different reasons
but one of the most famous of the mughal
royals is one who was never actually an
emperor himself he was a prince who much
like his predecessor akbar is not
remembered for political reasons but for
his explorations of religious and
intellectual
pursuits being an initiate and teacher
of the
sufi order as well as deeply and
seriously exploring the religious
traditions of the hindus this figure
represents the fascinating ways that
religious traditions can meet and
be in dialogue with each other without
necessarily being subsumed into each
other so in this episode let's talk
about prince dara shukou
[Music]
so
[Music]
was born in 1615 in india and as the son
of shahabadeen muhammad khuram more
famously known later as shah jahan the
emperor who built the magnificent taj
mahal
indeed dara's mother was mumtaz mahal
the queen in whose honor the taj mahal
was built after her death
dada was thus the grandson of the
emperor jahangir and great grandson of
the emperor akbar the early years of
dara and his siblings were tumultuous
being caught up in bloody struggles of
succession between his father uncles and
grandfather a common theme in the mughal
dynasty and one that dawada himself
would experience firsthand towards the
end of his life eventually though his
father won the war of succession and was
crowned the new mughal emperor under the
name shah jahan
and after this dara spent much of his
life with the privileges of a prince of
a mighty empire together with his
siblings including his sister jahanara
whom he was very close with for the rest
of his life and shared many spiritual
explorations with as well as his famous
or perhaps infamous younger brother
aurangzeb
dara was clearly the favorite though he
was shah jahan's eldest son and the
father doesn't exactly hide the fact
that dada was definitely considered heir
apparent
we can see indications of this in the
fact that when dada married his beloved
wife nadira in 1633 the celebrations
were grand beyond anything that had ever
been seen before whereas the marriages
of his brothers aurangzeb and shuja were
while still major events of course
still meager by comparison
we might also notice that while shah
jahan would often send his other sons
aurongzeb in particular to the far
reaches of the empire to constantly
fight wars or defend its borders dada
was mostly kept at home in the security
of the palaces something that some
historians theorized might have
contributed to his later downfall the
relationship between dada and his sister
was always warm and close for the rest
of their lives but he wasn't always on
good terms with his brothers they grew
up together of course but very early on
in their adult life we start to see
tensions between the different brothers
aurangzeb and the other younger brothers
were probably jealous of the favoritism
shown towards dada and while the
relationship between these brothers
generally would of course wax and wane
during their lives they we can sort of
see a gradual decline which eventually
would lead to complete disaster but
we're getting a bit ahead of ourselves
here because it isn't really a dada's
political life that we are interested in
here even if it does serve as an
important backdrop instead what is so
interesting about darashuko was his
intense piety and devotion to islam as
expressed through sufism now what's
important to remember here is that
sufism known as tasawolf in arabic
served as a kind of majority expression
of islam at this time islam and sufism
was basically synonymous
the different sufi orders that
flourished in the region at the time the
chishti khadiri and nakshbandi being
three examples and its different
spiritual masters was the focal point of
devotional practice
and all the famous emperors were deeply
connected to these orders in some way
emperors like akbar jahangir and even
aurangzeb would visit the shrines of
sufi masters and engage in their
teachings one very common mistake in
which this situation is presented is to
picture sufis on the one hand and then
conservative orthodox ulama or islamic
scholars on the other who oppose it
there was no such dichotomy back then it
didn't exist this is an anachronistic
and inaccurate way of portraying the
situation taking a modern situation and
projecting it backwards in history
because in the absolute majority of
cases the so-called orthodox scholars
were also sufis when we see certain sufi
practices or ideas being criticized this
isn't a debate between
sufis versus non-sufi orthodox islam
because no such dichotomy existed
instead these are debates and
discussions that are held within a sufi
context
sufis in other words muslims disagreed
on things they had different ideas about
what constituted correct islamic or sufi
practice this is an important point that
will become relevant again later on in
the discussion and we will return to it
darashuku was a muslim and it seems that
early on in his life he became
especially and intensely devoted to
sufism
some stories suggest that this devotion
and this interest may have been sparked
by a meeting with the famous khadiri
sufi
who lived in lahore at that time famous
not only as a master of the
sufi order but also supposedly as the
person who lay the foundation stone for
the sikh golden temple in amritsar
even though this story may or may not be
historically true it does kind of tell
us something about the religious
interactions between different religious
traditions at the time something that
definitely will become relevant in the
life story of dara it is said that the
emperor shah jahan visited myanmed in
his sufi lodge and brought the prince
dara with him
these kinds of meetings with ascetics
and religious
figures such as myanmed were quite
common at the time emperors would often
visit these kinds of sufi sages to
receive their blessings or to engage in
spiritual discussions in this case it
seems that shah jahan visited me on meat
in order for the sufi to help him cure
an illness that dada was afflicted with
which he promptly did and himself seems
to become completely overwhelmed by this
meeting and immediately becoming devoted
to this great sufi master dara would
continue to visit myanmed many times and
the great ascetic would teach him
mystical secrets and kadhiri practices
in which the prince would engage he was
on his way to becoming a proper sufi
unfortunately dada's time as a disciple
of myanmed was short as the master
passed away in 1635
leaving the prince still a novice on the
sufi path and without a master
amiami would continue to play a major
role in data spiritual and mystical
development even from the grave as we
will see but he could no longer serve as
a living guide in the physical world but
dara's destiny was by now firmly set
he was to dedicate the rest of his life
primarily to the sufi path and to the
qadhari order in particular
while he never gave up on his princely
duties and the fact that he was to
become the emperor the majority of
dada's activities for the rest of his
life would revolve around intellectual
and spiritual pursuits at this time both
dara and his sister jahanara started
diving deep into sufi literature both
classics and contemporary works this
included one of the most common and
popular genres the biographical or
hydrographical writings which describes
the lives and stories of sufi masters of
the past
many of the great sufi authorities wrote
such works including the nafahat al-uns
by abdul rahman jammi the tadkira
telauliyah by fareed nathar and the
rohls by evan arabi and as a result of
this data and johanna both decided to
write such high geographical works of
their own which it is claimed they both
finished on the same day on the 21st of
january 1640. jahanada had become
particularly attached and devoted to the
chishti order of sufism and her work
entitled the muniz al-arawa the
confidant of souls was a compendium of
stories about the great chishti saints
in particular al-dara's book by the name
safina de laulia the ship of god's
friends was more ambitious in scope
retelling stories of sufis from many
different orders writing such a work of
biographical material was a way to
assert oneself as a participant in the
sufi tradition something that both dara
and his sister were very interested in
doing and not too long after the death
of myanmir the prince found another
master in the figure mullah badashi
mulasha recited in kashmir and had been
a student of miyamir after whose death
he took on an increasingly essential
role
he had become famous as a sufi who had
reached an intense spiritual realization
of the principle of tawheed and
the unity of being
at once an authority on islamic law and
hadith and an occasionally controversial
figure for certain poetic utterances
during moments of mystical union mullah
would play a decisive role in the lives
of darashoku and his sister johannara
both of whom would eventually become his
devoted students but not without some
struggle
dada first met mulasha in 1640 at the
age of 25 when he together with the
emperor and his entourage visited
kashmir dada had of course heard of the
master being connected to myanmar and
desperately wanted him to take the
prince on as a student
mulasha however seems to have despised
worldly leadership and wanted to detach
himself completely from any such
connections
being a prince dara was harshly rejected
by the ascetic
after having approached the master
saying quote i am a seeker of god and
have come to the threshold for spiritual
guidance muller shaw i exclaimed quote
what have i got to do with emperors and
princes i'm an ascetic with no desires
what sort of time is this to come and
give me a headache and make trouble get
lost and don't come again
eventually however after repeated tries
and some help from mutual friends
muleshot agreed to take the prince on as
a student and dada started an intense
program of mystical practice during the
month that he stayed in kashmir he was
eventually initiated formally into the
qatari order by mullah shah and it
appears that the ascetic completely
changed his mind on the prince the two
becoming very close and mundashah
admiring the devotion of his student
considering him among his foremost
pupils dara seems to have progressed on
the spiritual path unusually fast and
before he left kashmir to go back home
mulasha had given him the permission to
teach
in other words dada had now become a
sufi teacher himself an accomplished
mystic who as a result of that had
surpassed his predecessors of the mughal
dynasty all of whom had been interested
in sufism and devoted to the sufi
saiyans and so on but had never actually
become official sufi practitioners
themselves and this religious
development continued for the rest of
dara's life he continued to serve as a
student for mulasha visiting him on
several occasions and corresponding
through letters when they were separated
but dada would also start to teach
himself and dedicated himself to
developing his own approaches writing
works of sufi literature as well as
engaging in debates and discussions with
different people in the region we really
start to see darashuku coming into his
own as a sufi personality and teacher as
he starts having intense visionary
experiences
once in 1642 where he saw his master
miyan mead impose upon him an ecstatic
experience of mystical union with god
and then another experience in 1645
in which he saw the prophet muhammad
himself
in the words of the historian and
scholar supriya gandhi quote
dara now saw the prophet
an unbroken chain of spiritual descent
immediately became apparent to him
from the prophet muhammad most beloved
of god the line of leadership went
straight to abdul qadr jillani founder
of the qadhari order eventually reaching
mulasha and through mulasha to darashuko
himself
in the vision the prince was then
appointed to write a treatise showing
the path to the divine this treatise
which he finished in 1646 or 1647 was
entitled the resale
which can be translated to something
like the compass of truth as the quote
suggested this is a book that is meant
to show the path to reaching the divine
through explicating and explaining a
number of spiritual and meditative
practices of the quality order and
general sufi doctrines related to it and
it is a good idea to explore this treaty
a bit deeper since it is probably the
best look into the actual teachings and
philosophies that darashoku adhered to
the treatise is primarily meant as a
guide for meditative and spiritual
practices a few of which are actually
described in great detail in the book
this is quite unusual for the time
especially because these kinds of
mystical practices were usually kept
secret and only
divulged by a teacher to an initiated
student but tada here seems to make a
point to
reveal these
teachings these these practices to
anyone who reads his book which
granted was probably quite a small elite
audience but still the two primary
meditative techniques that are described
in the treatise are according to its
author common practices in the kaduri
sufi order and he's very careful to
trace these practices back to the
order's founder abdul khadr al-jilani as
well as even back to the prophet
muhammad himself
these practices include on the one hand
a technique of suspension of the breath
which includes several postures and
another practice that aims to hear a
kind of primordial sound of existence
which when heard increases and takes
over your entire being and plunges the
mystic into an ecstatic
state he calls this the sultanas god and
explains how tradition tells that this
is the practice that the prophet
muhammad would partake in in the hira
cave prior to revelation and the sound
that is heard which is described as a
kind of hum or of running water a
beehive or sometimes the ringing of
bells is the same as the famous sound
that the prophet is said to have always
heard in connection to a new revelation
from god but the treatise also tells us
a lot about dara's more metaphysical or
ontological positions
generally it is clear that dara like so
many other muslims at the time follow
the teachings or school associated with
the andalusian sufi ibn arabi which has
become known as
or the unity of being he even alludes to
this pretty clearly himself in the
opening of the treatise quote by this
they might understand the essential
meaning of all the great sufi books such
as al-futu makiya and fusuz al-hikham by
ibn arabi and commentaries on them like
the savannah of ahmed razali
by mawlana jami and lama art by
fakhruddin iraqi here he clearly
connects himself with several scholars
attributed to this school of thought
with the exception of ahmed razali who
lived before eben arabi so that doesn't
make any sense but still i've dedicated
full episodes to this school of thought
which you can check out but it can be
characterized as a form of monistic
interpretation of islam where the only
reality reality itself in fact is
identified with god
all appearance in the created world is
the reflection of god's infinite
attributes having no being or existence
in themselves all created things are
nothingness their being or boujoud is
god and thus one and unified just like
god is dara shows his adherence to this
philosophy by making several comparisons
like the classic one of created things
being the waves in the ocean the ocean
itself being existence or god
he also compares it to ice and snow
different things which at the end of the
day are made up of the same stuff
namely water
quote consider the reality of water when
water is not bound it is free of color
and has no fixed form
but when water is bound in a solid it
assumes various forms such as ice or
snow or hail
observe closely and decide for yourself
whether or not ice snow and hail consist
of the same essential water which is
itself colorless and formless or the
following statement quote if you imagine
that a single moat of dust is separate
from the divine essence then you have
lost the blessing of witnessing divine
unity and mystical comprehension but
what is also really interesting about
is the fact that it gives us the first
indications of dara's engagement with
indict thought and hinduism in
particular
firstly and most clearly a lot of these
spiritual or meditative practices that
are described
even though dara is of course very
careful
to trace them back to the prophet
muhammad and his practices
and this might be a legitimate
connection it's hard to say but still
many of these practices have clear
parallels in yogic practices that were
common in the region at the time we know
that muslim and hindu ascetics had been
in contact and in dialogue for a long
time already by this point and that they
influenced each other
it's clear that the sufis had adopted
certain yogic practices and consider
them to be legitimate religious practice
the connection with hinduism and its
ideas would continue to be a significant
part of dada's legacy from then on and
here it's important to have one of those
in nuancing discussions again firstly
and as discussed in the episode about
akbar religious and intellectual
interactions between muslims and
non-muslims in this region was not
something uncommon at this time the
perspectives on these matters by
scholars at the time were significantly
more nuanced than many may imagine today
we have seen that authorities engaged in
translation and interpretation of
significant hindu texts like the
bhagavad-gita for example we see sufi
writers like abdulrahman al-shishti
commenting on the bhagavad-gita
theorizing that deities like krishna and
rama were in fact prophets of god just
like muhammad and jesus and that just
like with christianity or judaism
hinduism was originally a religion
revealed by god that had gone astray
thus many saw value in some of the
teachings that this tradition contained
it didn't escape people on both sides at
the time that there were significant
similarities between islam as understood
through sufism and under influence of
ideas like
in particular and hindu traditions like
advaita vedanta
even long before dada's time muslim
emperors and scholars had engaged in
meeting hindu ascetics and discussing
with them considering them to hold
divine wisdom just like a muslim saint
would
one very famous example is of the
emperor jahangir who on multiple
occasions met with the hindu ascetic
chidarab who lived in a hillside in
ujjain jidrip being caught well versed
in the science of vedanta and jahangir
being a muslim they engaged in
discussions where both affirm that the
same truth was being expressed in
different languages expressing an
attitude that had become increasingly
common at the time indeed the courtier
muhammad khan wrote that quote these
days the science of vedanta is taken to
mean tasawaf or sufism indicating that
many at the time saw the two traditions
as essentially expressing the same
divine truth
it is also important to remember that
clear categories like quote-unquote
hindu as it is used today didn't really
exist or function in the same way back
then hindu or hinduism is of course a
term that was used by outsiders to
describe groups within india and at this
time we see
the term hindu used to refer to specific
groups which is contrasted to other
groups like the rajputs for example who
by today's standards would also be
considered hindus but by the
characterizations and identifications of
the people at the time hindus were a
specific group there was something else
than the rajputs for example or
several other groups or identifiers at
that time muslim scholars at the time
had a nuanced view of the hindu
tradition of course looking with some
disdain towards any form of idolatry but
at the same time affirming that many
so-called hindus fell under the category
of monotheists the non-dualist school of
advaita vedanta or vedanta in general
were seen as essentially monotheistic
tradition which could thus be compared
and even connected to islam in some ways
so this is important to keep in mind as
we go forward darashuko in his
interactions with quote-unquote hinduism
wasn't as unique as you might think
he followed in a tradition of
inter-religious dialogue that was
flourishing in the region at the time
because indeed from this moment on we
see dara increasingly engage more and
more with other religious traditions as
containing expressions of divine truth
he would study deeply some of the hindu
classics like the ramayana and engage
much like his predecessors with meetings
and discussions with different hindu
ascetics the most legendary of these
personal interactions is dada's frequent
meetings with a hindu sage by the name
baba lal who leans strongly to the
non-dualist teachings of advaita vedanta
which teaches that the ultimate reality
or brahman is identical to all
appearance and the individual self or
atman as you might expect this attracted
daughter greatly as he could see so many
similarities with the teachings of islam
at least as he understood them through
the philosophy of
babalal was endearingly called the
shaven headed and dada refers to him as
caught one of the most perfect gnostics
the two engaged in long debates about
the different teachings of the different
religions there are similarities and
differences for dara and most of his
contemporaries babalal definitely fell
under the category of a monotheist and
thus could be greatly revered as a
teacher of sacred wisdom even though he
wasn't a muslim this can be seen in
dara's next major writing entitled
hasanat al-arafin fine words of the
gnostics which is a collection of
ecstatic utterances by various sufi
authorities a controversial topic these
utterances have been an important part
of sufi history and expression with the
most famous example probably being
al-halaj's exclamation anal
or i am the truth in daras vast
collection of these utterances meant as
a kind of justification for his own sufi
ideas and claims he also includes
non-muslims namely babalal and the
famous mystic kabir whose status as a
muslim or non-muslim is contested this
shows that dara did not consider divine
truth to be exclusive to muslims but
could also be reached at least partly by
practitioners of other traditions
and in the same work he stated clearly
himself quote
in every community and in every garb
there are visible and hidden friends of
the divine truth and this idea only
seems to have intensified as we reach
the final years of dara's life
after a military expedition in khan
dahad in 1654
dara started surrounding himself with
sanskrit scholars as well as
representatives of other religions like
christianity and judaism such
quote-unquote hindu scholars of sanskrit
were easy to come by as many of them
were employed in the court of shah jahan
with whom dara by now shared a status of
almost co-emperorship his studies into
schools like advaitha vedanta
intensified as he surrounded himself
with all these scholars
and all of these activities culminated
in what is one of dada's most famous
works
in 1655 by now 47 years old he wrote a
treatise entitled majmal bahrain meaning
the meeting place of the two oceans
as the title suggests this is in essence
a comparative work the two oceans in the
title referring to on the surface at
least islam and hinduism but remember
that these categories were much more
nuanced back then in the ed scholar
supriya gandhi importantly points out
that quote the prince refers to two
religious traditions but these are not
the crystallized rigidly bounded islam
and hinduism that we know in modern
times
his project does not seek to synthesize
two separate streams of islam and hindu
religion instead he aims to uncover and
document a common font of truth shared
by muslim and non-muslim indian
monotheists the book which was meant for
a very specific elite audience close to
dada and never for the broad public
compares teachings terms and ideas
within islam and hinduism showing which
different terms correspond to each other
and emphasizing the common ground that
the traditions share
dara himself writes in the treatise
quote this fakir without a care muhammad
rashoko relates that he after discerning
the truth of all truths asserting the
mysteries of the subtleties of the sufi
school of truth and attaining this
magnificent divine gift has approached
this purpose namely to comprehend the
nature of the school of thought of the
monotheists of india muwahidan hind and
the attainers of truth the muharram
among this ancient people with some of
them who have attained perfection who
have reached the extremities of ascetic
practice comprehension and understanding
and the utmost level of mystical
experience god seeking in gravity he in
other words darashuku has had repeated
encounters and carried out dialogues and
then he very clearly confirms quote
apart from linguistic differences in
discerning and knowing i saw no
divergence from this perspective i
brought together the words of both
parties and collected some terms that
are essential and valuable for the
secret of truth to know and arrange them
in a treatise while as we have seen data
is here taking part in an already
existing tradition of inter-religious
dialogue this treaty and quotes are
still remarkable it shows a huge level
of clarity comparative skill and
openness to considering new ideas while
still remaining firmly grounded in his
native religion of islam at least
according to himself the treatise is
filled with quotes from and references
to the quran a source that pervades the
entire enterprise while also remaining
comparative in its essential nature
quote the project takes as its primary
object of study the domain of india's
knowledge which it seeks both to
describe using its own vocabulary as
well as translate into islamic largely
sufi categories the majmal bahrain
remains a huge part of dara's legacy and
is one of the most famous
things that he is famous for but he
didn't stop there during the last years
of his life dada's translation project
continued and intensified dada's purpose
with all of these translations was his
passionate attempt to try to find the
most primordial and ancient truths about
god's oneness which he sought to find in
these ancient indian texts which he saw
as the most ancient of all monotheistic
texts and finally donna believed that he
had found the ultimate example of this
in one of the most ancient and important
scriptures in all of the hindu tradition
the upanishads a part of the larger
vedic corpus the upanishads are a
collection of philosophically and
mystically oriented texts that deal with
primary subjects like the brahman
absolute reality and ataman the self as
well as their relationship to each other
and which serves as the basis for the
vast hindu tradition of vedanta dara was
very excited by this prospect and
surrounded himself with a group of
censored scholars including the
brilliant kabindracharya to translate a
select collection of upanishads into
persian again the prince believed that
the upanishads were texts that could
unlock interpretations and secrets
within the quran and complement the
sacred scripture of the muslims by being
the most primordial revelation sent to
humankind and thus agreeing with its
divine message the upanishads as
scripture was the source of monotheism
and toheed thought himself writes about
the upanishads quotes
in which are contained all the secrets
of mystical path and meditative
exercises of pure divine unity he called
this very ambitious collection of
translated upanishads the siri akbar or
the greatest secret which tells us
something about his view of the role
that the translation played now remember
he engages with these scriptures in this
way without ever abandoning his devotion
to islam and the gradusufi order he
didn't seek to replace islam with hindu
revelation but saw the hindu scriptures
as complements that could help muslims
and other monotheists on their path to
divine unity and intimacy kind of
similar to the way that early muslim
philosophers view the relationship of
islam to greek philosophy but of course
sometimes the contents of the upanishads
have very openly polytheistic themes
which of course can create problems for
this syncretistic interpretation
da's translation and commentary does
here is very interesting
the text of course often refers to
deities or gods of the hindu pantheon
like brahma and vishnu and here the
prince engages in some of that really
fascinating comparative work instead
understanding these characters as angels
rather than gods
thus brahma becomes another name for the
angel jibril vishnu is identified with
the angel mikhail etc
now this was the first translation of
the upanishads into persian and dara's
siri akbar became a very popular and
famous document surviving beyond the
years of the prince's life
indeed the syria akbad was the first
exposure that many western scholars of
hinduism had to the upanishads at large
and thus served as a very important
factor in that field and in the history
of the spread and understanding of these
ancient scriptures the prince was
convinced that he had stumbled upon
something very important and significant
both by bringing into life the
upanishads to a persian audience and
thereby opening it up for further
discussion about the shared features and
truths of different expressions of
monotheism or divine oneness but these
fortunes were short-lived unfortunately
as daughter's life was just about to be
turned completely upside down
well
his life was about to end
indeed when the emperor shah jahan
suddenly fell gravely ill
a bloody war of succession broke out
between his sons and in particular very
intense fighting took place between
darashuko and his younger brother aurang
zeb perhaps due to the relative military
inexperience on dara's part or
probably other circumstantial factors
aurangzeb soon got the upper hand he
forced dara and his family and
supporters to flee across india and
crowned himself the new emperor under
the title of alamgir or the world caesar
soon dada and his family were captured
and aurangzeb very quickly realized that
the prince his older brother was quite
popular he was very popular with the
general population both muslims and
non-muslims and this was of course a
huge threat to his new authority
and this is what leads us to that very
tragic end of our story when aurangzeb
has his brother darashoku executed this
is a very famous story told and retold
across history
and it often
it's given very religious undertones and
themes aurangzeb is the orthodox
puritanical muslim who executes his
liberal and open-minded brother dada but
this of course as you might imagine is
quite a modern anachronistic way of
looking at this situation indeed
aurangzeb does use religious language in
justifying his execution of his brother
and during the war of succession but
it's never clear what this heresy is
supposed to be instead all claims
references to dada's supposed heretical
doctrines and engagement with hindus and
so on really come after he was already
executed probably as a way to justify
what was essentially a political
decision after the fact because history
would indeed remember these two brothers
in very different ways aurangzeb is a
very controversial figure some say he is
the most hated man in indian history
under his leadership the mughal empire
reached its peak in terms of territorial
expanse but many also claimed that his
rulership was the beginning of the end
and that he was a tyrannical oppressive
ruler the way aurangzeb is remembered is
often as a champion of a more
quote-unquote orthodox or conservative
puritanical islam in contrast to other
mughal royals like dara or his
predecessors like akbar for those
muslims who like that kind of stuff this
is a positive thing but for others it is
a great tragedy
but how accurate is this common
portrayal how different was aurangzeb
and dada really as you might guess it's
a big oversimplification and mistake to
make a clear dichotomy between aurangzeb
as representing quote-unquote orthodox
islam and dara on the other side of the
spectrum
not only because the two weren't all
that different in terms of their
religious beliefs and affiliations but
also because such a one-sided view fails
to take the nuance of this context into
consideration darashuko considered
himself to be a truly orthodox muslim
and his teachings and ideas very much
represented major movements within islam
at that time
he as a kaduri sufi did not stand in
opposition to some orthodox school of
scholars as we saw earlier this kind of
division didn't exist back then
for many fellow muslims and scholars at
the time dada's activities were entirely
legitimate
and aurangzeb after all wasn't all that
different he too was deeply involved
with sufism was devoted to the chishti
saints for example
many of those muslims today who admire
aurangzeb as a defender of true faith
would probably not be very happy with a
lot of his perspectives on islam we
shouldn't see the conflict between the
two brothers as one between orthodox
islam and unorthodox islam and
definitely not as between orthodox islam
and sufism because indeed
the word orthodoxy is always a relative
and fluid term defined by those who
claim to be following it and changing
with time and place a more helpful way
to understand the situation is as a
conflict between different
understandings of islam rather than
between islam and its opposite if we do
the latter then islam itself becomes the
problem because we are defining it as
such that the more muslim one is the
bigger the problem aurangzeb was more
puritanical because he was more muslim
more religious than dara but this is
simply not the case
arguably in some ways dada was more
religious than aurangzeb more devoted to
islam than his younger brother but at
the end of the day these terms aren't
useful at all the two brothers simply
understood the boundaries of their
religion differently but even all of
this is supposing that aurangzeb was
indeed dramatically different from data
and doctrine which isn't all that
accurate either now you can't deny that
aurangzeb does come off as a somewhat
more strict and rigid compared to his
predecessors he styled himself as a
strictly islamic ruler did things like
forbid music in court at least for a
period reestablished the jazee attacks
he had several hindu temples destroyed
etc there's a lot more nuance to this
discussion itself but i will have to
wait for another thorough discussion of
aurongzeb's rule in particular but he
isn't as different as many tend to
believe
many like to speculate about what india
would have been like if dada had won the
war of succession and become the emperor
honestly probably not all that different
dada was also from the same environment
it's highly liked it and he would have
had aurangzeb killed if he had got the
upper hand instead and the realities of
rulership would have probably led him
down similar paths bottom line is we
should do our best to avoid the common
black and white narratives about this
topic
it is simply not the case that aurangzeb
was universally considered more orthodox
or more islamic it is simply not the
case that aurangzeb had the backing of
the religious islamic scholars while
being hated by hindus and that data
being despised by the islamic scholars
unliked by the hindu population when we
look at the armies of the two brothers
during the war of succession and their
general supporters at this time we find
even numbers between them
dada had just as many muslims and muslim
scholars who supported his side as
aurangzeb did and they both had an equal
amount of hindus who strongly supported
their claim to the throne clearly things
aren't so simple and history has often
projected later construction onto a
context that simply doesn't work that
way the way we conceal these events and
the status of these different figures
says more about us and our own
environment than it does about the
historical period and people we are
actually describing history is never
black or white and this is no exception
both dara shuku and aurangzeb are men of
their times
dara in his exploration and interactions
with various strands of indic thought as
an extension of his sufi piety and
muslim devotedness embodied attitudes
and movements in the religious
environment of his time
in some ways he isn't all that unique
but in other ways he's of course
incredibly fascinating he may strike us
as an unusual kind of muslim
intellectual judging by today's
standards and the way that the religious
landscape of india looks at the current
moments but at the time that he lived
his approach to religion and religious
diversity represented one way of
understanding islam sufism and our quest
for divine unity
one way among many that have existed in
the long history of islam and the world
religions
i hope you found this to be an
interesting overview of darashuku's life
and teachings if you want a more
thorough
look into these subjects i highly
recommend a recent book written by the
scholar supriya gandhi entitled the
emperor who never was this is one of the
primary sources i have used for this
video this book is really the only
proper overview or biography of dara and
his ideas and i can't recommend this
book enough it straddles the boundaries
between being incredibly readable and
interesting and engaging while at the
same time being deeply
scholarly and very competently written
from that perspective too so check out
this book if you are interested more in
this subject
if you want to support this channel and
its attempts to give you
free content about the world's different
religious traditions then consider
supporting us on patreon or through a
one-time donation on paypal and i of
course also
highly appreciate you everyone who likes
subscribes and comments on these videos
thank you so much and i will see you
next time
special shout out to my new saints
sohail gokal and mary carmen orodonis
and of course a thank you to all of my
patrons who make this channel possible
[Music]
you